a teacher once told me I was the  mistress of self reinvention it's like  having a secret  and nobody but me knows I'm doing it  I saw her I saw her from the Train  she was she was with this man just for a  second  is this her timid soul can you tell me  where you were Friday night I was in the  city and then I went to visit my husband  you mean your ex-husband it's my  understanding that the woman who has  gone missing  who is his nanny Rachel I need you to  stay away so what did you do during  those hours that night  I don't remember that's some time Missy  what happened at night I don't know tell  me the truth  you were seen in the area that night  did you murder Megan Hipwell No  I'm not the girl I used to be  why are you here because I'm afraid of  myself your man looking at the world  through a keyhole  you've spent your life trying to widen  it